there are so many lessons that we've
learned over the past
year and a half to two years that i
think prepare us to be ready for the
next future um i got a kick out of
during the height of covid uh the number
of pundits who said during these
unpredictable times i would smile and
say
all times are unpredictable there's
never been a time that was predictable
ever
all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened that reminded
us
that our lives and our work is
unpredictable and to future proof
ourselves means being ready for the
unpredictable um there's something
called an infinite mindset and those
with an infinite mindset embrace
surprise uh they find opportunity in the
unexpected that when something goes
haywire they go ooh what can we do with
this
versus a finite mindset which likes to
exert control and keep things very very
close and time frames short because they
fear the uncertain they fear anything
that's off the plan and one of the
things that we have to do to pro to
future proof ourselves is to embrace
things that are surprises and embrace
the opportunity in uncertainty
the other thing that i think we have to
learn on how to future proof ourselves
is how to deal with stress and how to
deal with trauma um uh whether somebody
uh did well during covid uh
business-wise or whether they struggled
business-wise all of us
all of us suffered some sort of trauma
and when i when covent first showed up i
called a friend of mine who's active
duty military and i asked him during
when you're in combat what do you do
to compartmentalize your emotions so you
can stay mission focused my business
blew up
right in front of me and i had to focus
on my mission of rebuilding my business
i wanted to know how to control my
emotions so i could get the work done
that i had to get done
and he gave me a very sobering warning
he said no one can compartmentalize
their emotions he says we can do it for
a short period of time but everyone will
suffer the trauma of combat sometimes
many months after we get home and he
said you will go through it
maybe not now but you will go through it
and
sure sure enough about four or five
months in
i started to feel extremely off my game
and i called him up and i said can i
just ask you
you know uh what are your symptoms when
you go through the
the trauma of combat i asked no leading
questions i said what are your symptoms
he said well
one i fall out of my sleep pattern for
some reason i go to bed late for no
reason and i don't want to get up in the
morning and i thought to myself
yup
and he said i become unproductive and i
rationalize it like oh you've been
working hard it's okay if you have an
unproductive day or two
but then i have another and another and
another and i thought to myself yup
and he said i also become extremely
antisocial i don't want to talk to
anyone i definitely don't want to ask
for help
and i thought to myself
yup
and i realized i was going through
depression i was afraid to use that word
for fear that it sounded like a
diagnosis but it was little d depression
that's exactly what i was going through
which is why things weren't working and
so i asked my friend again so how do you
overcome it he said one you have to
force yourself to get back into your
sleep pattern and two you have to force
yourself to ask people for help
and that's exactly what i was doing and
i reached out to friends that i trusted
friends that i loved people who i knew
were dispensers of good advice
and i called them one by one and said
i'm going through this what can i do i
also reached out to friends who i knew
were going through similar things and
offered my support for them because
that's one of the things i've learned in
my career which is the best way to solve
your problems is to help people who are
going through the same thing and so to
understand how to react under extreme
stress
to understand
and build the relationship so that when
you do go through something you know who
to call
my rule during covert and i called all
my a-type personality friends and gave
them my rule which is there's no crying
alone and the question i would ask every
one of you is if you start to cry who
are you going to call
who will you pick up the phone and just
say i need to cry and tell them what's
going on
it is much healthier to know that
someone will give you a shoulder and be
there to support you no matter what
you're going through